um hopefully i look as good as that he
was running quite fast there
the twilight saga new moon took us
twihards deep into the mythology of
vampires werewolves and everything in
between
but behind the movie magic was a cast
and crew who worked
impossibly hard to make sure everything
was perfect when it reached
the big screen from wolf pack camp to
groundbreaking special effects
let's dive into the behind the scenes of
new moon all right let's roll it
the first twilight film only skimmed the
surface when it came to stephanie
meyer's werewolf history
just like it was bella's new moon was
our first
tango with the truth behind the
quillutes that means the cgi and special
effects department had some big shoes to
fill
they used some advanced computer
technology to construct the werewolves
and used references from real life
timberwolves
they were then able to use these
digitized models and add them to the raw
footage
when it came to filming they used
plastic or cardboard stand-in werewolves
that kristen stewart tried to avoid
acting with at all times
it's like five seconds of me reacting
like
but for taylor filming as a wolf was
pretty exciting it allowed him to do
some of his own stunt wire work
and i'm glad to have the wolf the wolf
pack here now
robert pattinson also got to get
involved with the stunt coordinators
during edward's confrontation with the
volturi
while the stunt doubles took on most of
the intense action our paths
still stepped in and did some wire work
as well overall the valtteri fight scene
was intricately choreographed to run
smoothly
and took a lot of practice from both the
stunt doubles and the actors
at the end of the day rob was
congratulated with a cake because it was
his birthday
[Applause]
sadly kristen stewart didn't get to
become an expert motorcycle rider while
filming new moon
but she did get to have some fun
pretending to ride one
to keep kristen safe but also get as
many close-ups of her as possible they
secured bella's bike to a dolly platform
that carried the motorcycle while it
moved to give the appearance that
kristen was actually riding it
it was cool to be on the back of a
motorcycle on the back of a car
kristin had another opportunity to get
involved with some stunts but it was
just a little too risky
bella's birthday party at the cullens
may just be the most misleading scene
of the entire film the truth is that the
majority of the time the main cast
weren't even the ones filming
even characters not involved in the
vampire violence like rosalie and esme
were replaced with stunt doubles
bella and jasper's stunt doubles both
wore wires so that they could be
controlled when pushed back by edward
the glass bella falls into was fake
breakaway material to prevent the stunt
double from getting hurt
the real actors were carefully brought
in to film a bit of the choreographed
action
a part that jackson rathbone absolutely
loved
he put so much effort into his attack
that even kristen admitted that she was
terrified by his performance a little
bit of action a little bit of ducking
and jiving
creating the werewolves is one thing but
showcasing jacob's werewolf
powers in human form like his strength
took some added effort
in order to give the audience and bella
a hint of jacob's new strengths he
lifted his motorcycle out of bella's
truck
while it isn't far-fetched to think
taylor could have totally done it
without help
they attached the bike to wires and a
crane to make the lift look
effortless dude when did you get so
strong
speaking of effortlessness the cgi team
was able to make these behind the scenes
to big screen
transitions looks seamless production on
the saga changed from portland to
vancouver
after the first film which meant a lot
of the buildings we saw in the first
film were miles and
miles away the set designers were able
to put together or find replicas of
bella's home
and the cullen's home but locations like
forks high were completely recreated
with green screens
it's almost impossible to tell the cliff
diving sequence in new moon was finally
kristen's time to shine when it came to
trying out some stunts
but director chris weitz put some
expectations on kristen that just
weren't possible
yeah i like stunt work kind of scary
though
to give the appearance as if she was
drowning he asked kristen to put weights
in her pockets to allow
herself to sink with his experience from
harry potter rob was making all the
water work look like a piece of cake
so chris was a little apprehensive as to
why kristen was finding it all a bit
overwhelming
but when he decided to suit up and try
putting weights in his pockets as well
he realized that not only was kristin
right in being terrified
but rob was superhuman for not feeling
the same i decided to go down there in a
wetsuit waited down and i started to
panic
in the end it all worked out and looked
amazing
something else that turned out amazing
in the film the entire
italy sequence at the end but it wasn't
without a lot of work from everyone
involved
before even shooting the production team
went on a detailed tour of tuscany and
lombardi
in order to find the perfect location
because they were looking to keep a more
renaissance vibe
instead of a classic gothic vampire
approach they were very very picky
the choice of montepulciano was a sort
of big discussion and we really worked
on that to get it right
once they settled on a location they
were able to use it as
inspiration for creating the inner
workings of the volturi layer in the
studio
the costume department also faced some
challenges in italy
they had to find a quick way to be able
to put 700 extras in cloaks for the
valturi scene
when they were originally asked for 350.
it started off as 350. then it grew to
400
and then someone asked me well how many
do you really think you can do that
meant finding something that we could
fit multiple body types
we came up with a simple formula almost
like one size fits all
it may have taken a lot of hard work but
that italian sea of red was
incomparable on screen taylor lautner's
wardrobe also needed
a little extra attention from the
costume department in this film
even if he was shirtless for the
majority of it in the novel jacob is
supposed to have
drastically changed from one moment to
the next although taylor did have a big
transformation
they still had to make his appearance
more exaggerated we tailored
all of the t-shirts he wore to make it
seem like he was busting out of them
he also had lifts added to his shoes so
he would tower
over bella there wasn't much room for
improv in the twilight films because of
the franchise's complicated storyline
but
anna kendrick was able to show off her
skills in this scene with bella outside
of the movie theater
her speech about zombies totally
unscripted looks like chris white saw
her improv potential even before she
moved on to share her talents with the
pitch perfect team
and like it's supposed to be a metaphor
for consumerism
it wasn't all wire tricks and near
drownings for this cast
their chemistry and hilarious
personalities led to some of these
heartwarming bloopers on set but like
many film sets being a part of the new
moon cast did come with its own set of
rules
for the second film director chris weitz
made sure that every actor cast as part
of the wolf pack could prove they held
first
nation status he wanted to ensure he was
representing the quillutes properly
production designer david brispin even
met with the clilu executive council to
make sure they were being as
accurate as possible once those actors
were cast
they were sent straight to what chris
termed wolf camp
it's here they were trained by
professionals and were put on strict
diets that had to follow
chaske spencer who played sam found the
whole experience
pretty rewarding so what they did is he
threw us into circuit training and
muscle confusion workouts
and then we just eat all day it's pretty
much four to six meals a day plus three
to four protein shakes a day as well
despite the challenges that came along
with the film the cast and crew were
able to pull through
and continue on with the twilight saga
perfectly their attention to detail with
the volturi and beyond
added an extra layer to it all not to
mention the perfect chemistry between
the actors
what was your favorite behind the scenes
moment let us know below
thanks for watching we'll catch with you
later